Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Cassie: I WORRY ABOUT
WHAT I EAT 24-7.
Tyra: CASSIE
REVEALED AN OBSESSION
WITH HER BODY IMAGE...
Cassie:
I WANT TO BE A MODEL.
I FEEL LIKE I SHOULD
BE SKINNY.
Tyra: AND NORELLE
STRUGGLED ON THE RUNWAY.
Norelle: WHOA!
Audience: (gasps)
Tyra:
WHEN KELLE FAILED AGAIN
TO PROVE SHE WAS
PHOTOGENIC,
SHE WAS SENT PACKING.
EIGHT GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Eva: I JUST FELL
ON THE LAVA!
OH, MY GOD!
DON'T SAY THAT!
Amanda:
LONDON BRIDGE!
Norelle: DON'T FALL
IN THE LAVA.
Amanda:
ARE YOU A CHEERLEADER?
Eva: OH, MY GOD!
Ann: HOW FUNNY WAS THAT,
THE LAVA?
Cassie:
I'M JUST NOT HAVING FUN.
I DON'T WANT TO MISS
MY FAMILY,
AND I DON'T WANT
TO MISS MY BOYFRIEND,
BUT MY HEART IS HURTING
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S JUST REALLY SAD, LIKE,
THERE'S A SADNESS INSIDE OF ME.
LIFE CHANGES
IF YOU WIN THIS.
Cassie's boyfriend:
YEAH.
Cassie: YOU HAVE
TO MOVE TO NEW YORK.
YOU DON'T HAVE TIME FOR
A BOYFRIEND ANYMORE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TIME
TO DO ANYTHING EXCEPT WORK.
Cassie's boyfriend:
I MEAN, HEY,
YOU GOTTA DO
WHAT YOU GOTTA DO.
Cassie: WILL YOU
GO THERE WITH ME?
Cassie's boyfriend:
AM I GONNA COME WITH YOU?
WELL, I'M NOT JUST GONNA
PICK UP AND LEAVE.
Cassie: NO, C.J.!
I DON'T WANT
TO LET YOU GO.
I LOVE YOU.
Toccara: THAT CHICKEN'S
STARTING TO LOOK GOOD, THOUGH.
Yaya: SERIOUSLY,
YOU'RE GONNA GET SICK
IF YOU JUST LEAVE IT
LIKE THAT.
Toccara: I DO
LIKE THAT ALL THE TIME.
I MIGHT ROLL OVER IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT AND EAT SOMETHING.
MY MAMA EAT IN HER SLEEP.
Yaya:
THAT'S NOT GOOD.
Toccara: WHEN SHE BE ASLEEP,
SHE BE LIKE...
I LOVE MYSELF.
I LOVE MY SHAPE.
I LOVE MY CURVES.
SOME PEOPLE THINK
THAT AMERICA'S "NOT READY"
FOR A PLUS-SIZED MODEL.
I'M HERE
TO BREAK THAT NORM.
I WANT TO BE THE FIRST
BLACK PLUS-SIZED MODEL
TO BE ON THE COVER
OF 20 MAGAZINES.
I DON'T WANT
TO STAY IN MY CATEGORY.
I WANT TO GO INTO
THE "STRAIGHT SIDE."
Norelle: I WISH
I WAS MORE LIKE TOCCARA.
SHE'S FABULOUS.
SHE HAS CONFIDENCE
IN HERSELF.
CAN YOU SEE IT?
Ann: EVERYONE HAS THAT,
LIKE, I HAVE THAT.
Norelle: MY STOMACH
HAS, LIKE, A LITTLE PUDGE.
I WOULD LIKE IT
TO BE MORE ABBY,
AND I STILL HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF FLABBY.
(telephone ringing)
- Yaya: HELLO.
- Tyra: Hi, it's Tyra.
All right, I need you to get
everybody together, okay?
Because you guys are gonna
meet me for a little challenge.
Now you need to wear
some comfortable shoes,
but bring some
high heels, too.
Yaya:
GOOD MORNING, HELLO!
I JUST GOT A CALL
FROM TYRA.
WE HAVE TO DRESS
LIKE WE'RE GOING TO PANEL
AND BRING COMFORTABLE SHOES.
TYRA JUST CALLED.
WAKE UP.
Norelle: WE WERE TOLD
TO BRING FLATS AND HEELS.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHY.
Toccara: SHE'S WALKING
OUT THE DOOR.
♪♪♪
Tyra: HI, EVERYBODY.
Eva: HEY, TYRA.
Tyra: SO YOU GUYS HAVE BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD
FOR THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS.
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING WITH SOME
OF THE TOP PHOTOGRAPHERS,
BUT PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW YOU EXIST.
NOW IT'S TIME TO SEND YOU OUT
TO THE SHARKS.
YOU'RE GONNA EXPERIENCE
A DAY IN THE LIFE OF A MODEL
GOING ON GO-SEES DURING
FASHION WEEK.
A GO-SEE MEANS YOU
JUST GO SEE THE CLIENT
TO LET THEM KNOW THAT
YOU ARE ALIVE,
SO WE HAVE PUT TOGETHER
PORTFOLIOS HERE.
Girls: (squealing)
Eva: TYRA GAVE US
OUR PORTFOLIOS,
OUR BEST PHOTOS THAT
WE HAVE TAKEN THUS FAR.
I WAS SO STOKED.
IT WAS JUST SO EXCITING,
'CAUSE IT MAKES YOU FEEL LIKE,
"HEY, I'M MODELING.
I CAN DO THIS, TOO."
Ann: I'M THE ONE THAT HAS,
LIKE, THE WORST PORTFOLIO.
Nolé: YOUR BODY LANGUAGE
IS NOT GOOD.
Tyra: OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS,
YOU WERE THE WORST.
Ann: LAST WEEK I WAS IN
THE BOTTOM TWO FOR ELIMINATION.
Tyra: PRETTY GIRL,
NOT PHOTOGENIC.
Ann: BUT I FEEL
GOOD ABOUT GO-SEES,
BECAUSE IT'S IN PERSON,
AND IT'S NOT PICTURES.
THEY'LL LIKE ME IN PERSON,
AND I'M PRETTY IN PERSON.
Tyra: YOU'RE GONNA BE JUDGED
ON OVERALL LOOKS.
WE KNOW THIS IS
THE MODELING INDUSTRY,
SO IT IS ABOUT THE PHYSICAL.
YOU'RE GONNA BE JUDGED
ON YOUR WALK.
YOU'RE ALSO GONNA BE
JUDGED ON YOUR PERSONALITY.
OF COURSE, WHOEVER GETS
THE MOST PRAISE
GETS AN AMAZING PRIZE--
A RACK OF CLOTHES...
Eva: OH, MY...
Tyra: ...FROM EACH DESIGNER
THAT YOU SEE TODAY.
THESE GIRLS
ARE SO LUCKY.
I SET UP FOR THEM TO HAVE
GO-SEES WITH FIVE
OF THE TOP DESIGNERS
IN NEW YORK CITY--
DIANE VON FURSTENBERG,
NANETTE LEPORE,
MARC BOUWER,
CYNTHIA ROWLEY
AND NICOLE MILLER.
Ann: GOING TO THE GO-SEES,
I KNOW I HAVE TO MAKE
THE RIGHT IMPRESSION,
YOU KNOW, COME ACROSS
AS BEING SOMEONE THAT
THEY WANT TO WORK WITH.
Nicole Miller:
I'M NICOLE.
Ann: I'M ANN.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
Nicole Miller:
LIKE YOUR T-SHIRT.
- IT'S CUTE.
- Ann: THANK YOU.
IT'S DIFFERENT BEING
IN NEW YORK,
'CAUSE I'M SO NOT USED TO,
LIKE, FASHION AND STUFF.
Nicole Miller:
WELL, WE'RE CASTING FOR
OUR MILLER GIRL
FASHION SHOW,
SO WE WANT SOMEBODY WITH
A REALLY YOUNG, PEPPY LOOK.
SO WE'RE GONNA PUT
AN OUTFIT ON YOU,
AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA SEE HOW YOU WALK.
Ann:
SOUNDS GOOD.
Woman: GREAT LOOKS,
GOOD PERSONALITY.
♪♪♪
Nicole Miller: SO HOW'D YOU
GET THE NAME YAYA?
THAT'S SO UNUSUAL.
Yaya: IT'S ACTUALLY
REALLY COMMON IN WEST AFRICA.
Nicole Miller:
OKAY.
Toccara: NICOLE MILLER,
HER CLOTHES ARE GREAT.
THEY FIT ME, AND I FELT
VERY WONDERFUL IN THEM.
Norelle: HI.
Nicole Miller:
WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
Norelle: CALIFORNIA,
ORANGE COUNTY.
I DON'T THINK I'M THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL GIRL HERE.
LIKE, I'M SO, LIKE, FUNNY
AND RETARDED, LIKE, DORKY GIRL.
Nicole Miller: YOU'VE
NEVER DONE ANY MODELING?
AH.
Norelle: AND I JUST HOPE
THAT THEY SEE, LIKE,
SOME POTENTIAL IN ME.
Nicole Miller: NO, NO, NO,
NO, STOP RIGHT THERE.
MORE LIKE
AN ASSERTIVE WALK, OKAY?
Amanda: I WANTED
TO SLAP MYSELF
WHEN I SAW THAT
ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
HAVE HIGH HEELS WITH 'EM,
AND I DON'T.
Eva: YOU OF ALL PEOPLE
GONNA FORGET YOUR SHOES.
Amanda: I JUST
WASN'T THINKING.
Norelle: AMANDA
DIDN'T HAVE SHOES,
SO I LET HER
BORROW MY SHOES.
Amanda:
I GOTTA WEAR SHOES
THAT WERE ONE AND A HALF
SIZES TOO SMALL.
MY WALK'S VERY UNEVEN
AND KINDA LIKE,
SWAYED TO AND FRO.
Nicole Miller:
OKAY.
Amanda: RIGHT NOW
I NEED TO DO SOMETHING
THAT MAKES MY CONFIDENCE
HIGHER.
Ann:
AMANDA FORGOT HER SHOES,
SO SHE NEEDED TO RUN
TO THE STORE,
AND, OF COURSE,
WE ALL WANTED TO GO.
WE WANTED TO LOOK
AT SHOES.
AND SO AMANDA WENT,
EVA WENT, I WENT,
TOCCARA WENT
AND CASSIE WENT.
Amanda: 7 1/2, TALL STILETTO,
BRIGHT COLOR.
Ann: I LOVE SHOES.
Cassie: AND IT WAS
ONLY 15 MINUTES
BEFORE OUR NEXT GO-SEE.
♪♪♪
Yaya:
THIS IS A COMPETITION,
AND SO NOT ALL OF US
WERE RUNNING AROUND.
I UNDERSTAND IF ONE PERSON
NEEDS TO GET A PAIR OF SHOES,
BUT THE FACT THAT IT TURNED
INTO A FIELD TRIP,
I WAS NOT HAPPY.
Eva:
WHAT TIME YOU GOT?
Ann: WE HAD 15 MINUTES,
AND I THINK WE WERE THERE
A LITTLE LONGER.
♪♪♪
Toccara:
WHERE'S THE CAR?
OUR VEHICLES
HAD LEFT US, GONE.
GONE, JUST GONE.
(horn honks)
Cassie: OUR VAN IS GONE,
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
OUR NEXT GO-SEE IS.
Ann: WE WENT BACK UP
TO NICOLE MILLER.
Cassie: HI, DO YOU GUYS
HAVE OUR ITINERARY?
- I MEAN, THEY LEFT US.
- Eva: DO YOU?
Cassie: DO YOU KNOW ANYWHERE
ABOUT WHERE WE'RE GOING?
Woman: GO TO WEST 39th
BETWEEN 7th AND 8th.
Woman: EVA, DO YOU
WANT US TO HELP YOU?
Eva: PLEASE!
Ann: EVA!
- Toccara: EVERYONE IS GO--
- Ann: I'M NOT LEAVING EVA!
Toccara: WHAT IS IT?
Ann:
DAMN, DON'T RIP IT!
Toccara: 214!
Cassie: YOU GUYS LEFT ME!
WHAT THE HELL?
Toccara:
GET OUT OF THE WAY!
♪♪♪
Cassie: OUR VAN IS GONE,
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
OUR NEXT GO-SEE IS.
NONE OF US
WERE NEW YORKERS.
EVERYONE WAS FREAKING OUT.
Eva: THEY LEFT US.
DO YOU KNOW ANYWHERE
ABOUT WHERE WE'RE GOING?
Woman: GO TO WEST 39th.
Yaya: NICOLE, NORELLE
AND I ARRIVED FIRST,
AND WE WERE WAITING
IN THE LOBBY FOR THEM.
I FELT LIKE A HALF AN HOUR
WENT BY.
Cassie: WE WERE 20 MINUTES
LATE TO NANETTE LEPORE.
Eva: UP, I'M GOING UP.
Amanda:
WE'RE ALREADY LATE.
Cassie: COME ON, COME ON,
COME ON, WE'RE IN SUCH A HURRY.
Woman: HI,
WELCOME TO NANETTE LEPORE.
Man: MODELS.
Yaya: HI!
Nanette: NOW I HAVE
TO TELL EVERYONE
THAT YOU'RE
20 MINUTES LATE.
I'M VERY UPSET.
YOU REALLY HAVE TO MAKE
YOUR DEADLINES
IF YOU'RE SERIOUS ABOUT
HAVING A CAREER IN MODELING.
SO WE'RE GONNA BRING YOU
BACK IN ONE AT A TIME
AND JUST PLEASE REMEMBER,
IF YOU HAVE TO MEET
ANY KIND OF DEADLINE
WHERE I'M INVOLVED,
PLEASE RESPECT IT
FROM NOW ON.
Man: WHOSE FAULT WAS IT?
Eva: THERE WAS FIVE OF US.
Toccara: THERE WAS FIVE
OF US BUT...
Amanda: I'LL TAKE
ALL RESPONSIBILITY.
I DON'T THINK SHE UNDERSTOOD
THE FACT THAT IT WASN'T JUST ME.
Nanette: SO WHAT SIZE
ARE YOU?
Amanda:
UM, THESE ARE 25s.
I FELT TAKING RESPONSIBILITY
WOULD GET ME SOME POINTS,
BUT IT JUST MADE HER
REALLY DISLIKE ME.
Nanette:
OKAY, SO AMANDA.
I GAVE HER "HIPPYISH"
FOR PERSONAL STYLE,
A LITTLE
BIKER MEETS HIPPY.
Man: SHE'S ALSO REALLY
LONG-WAISTED.
SHE'S GOT REALLY SHORT LEGS.
Nanette: POOR THING.
NICOLE.
SHE LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S GOT IT ALMOST.
Man: YEAH.
EVA, I FIND SOMETHING
A LITTLE BIT PIGGY
ABOUT HER NOSE.
Nanette: I THOUGHT
SHE WAS THE MOST STRIKING
WHEN WE SAW THE WHOLE
GROUP TOGETHER.
Man: CASSIE.
Nanette: SHE'S GOT
A CUTE, YOUNG LOOK.
SHE MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT...
Man: HIPPY?
Nanette: SHE'S NOT EXACTLY
A SIZE 2.
THAT'S REALLY PRETTY.
Man: NORELLE.
I ACTUALLY THINK SHE LOOKS
BETTER IN HER PICTURES.
ANN, BE A LITTLE BIT
ALIVE IN YOUR FACE.
LIKE THAT.
Nanette: YEAH, THAT'S GOOD,
THAT'S GOOD.
Man: SO MUCH BETTER.
Yaya: JUST TO LET YOU KNOW,
THREE OF US WERE HERE
WAITING IN THE LOBBY
FOR A HALF AN HOUR.
Nanette: I KNOW.
Yaya: BUT WE DO REALLY
WANT TO BE HERE.
Nanette: I KNOW. I KNOW
THAT YOU WERE ON TIME.
Yaya: OKAY.
Man: SHE'S CUTE.
Nanette: SO SHE GETS
THE ADORABLE.
Toccara: I'M
A FULL-FIGURED MODEL.
I'M GONNA BE THE FIRST BLACK
PLUS-SIZED SUPERMODEL
IN THE WORLD.
Nanette: SHE GETS, LIKE,
DOUBLE STARS HERE
FOR PERSONALITY.
Man: SHE'S GOTTA,
LIKE, BREAK GROUND
IF SHE WANTS TO DO SOMETHING
IN MAINSTREAM FASHION,
WHICH IS NOT EASY
GROUND TO BREAK.
Toccara: WHAT SIZE SHIRT
IS THIS?
OKAY, SORRY.
Nanette: WE DIDN'T HAVE
YOUR SIZE.
Toccara:
IT'S ALL RIGHT. I'M SORRY.
THERE'S THESE CLOTHES
ON THESE RACKS,
AND ALL THE GIRLS,
THEY CAN PROBABLY FIT
EVERYTHING ON THERE,
YOU KNOW?
THEY BARELY FIND
ANYTHING THAT CAN FIT ME.
MY BREASTS LOOK OKAY?
Man: SHE WAS BUSTING OUT
OF THAT JACKET.
Nanette: AND THAT WOULD BE
THE BIGGEST SIZE WE CUT.
- Man: RIGHT.
- Nanette: WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO?
Man: WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO?
Toccara: IT IS
A FRUSTRATING THING
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
MY SIZE.
♪♪♪
Diane: JUST WEAR THE DRESS
AND LOOK BEAUTIFUL AND EASY.
Diane: TURN AROUND.
Eva: IT'S BASICALLY
A COMPETITION.
THE PERSON
WITH THE MOST POINTS
WILL WIN A RACK OF CLOTHES
FROM THE DESIGNER.
Diane:
WHEN I CAST A SHOW,
ILIKE THE GIRLS TO HAVE THEIR
OWN PERSONALITY, IN A SENSE.
AND OF COURSE,
THEY MUST KNOW HOW TO WALK.
Norelle: I AM PROUD
OF MYSELF.
I DIDN'T FALL,
AND I DIDN'T SLIP.
Diane:
WHY ARE YOU SMILING?
Norelle:
'CAUSE I'M HAPPY.
Diane: OKAY.
SHE DOESN'T WALK
THAT GREAT.
Woman: IT'S HARD
FOR THEM TO WALK.
Diane: YEAH, BUT EVEN
THE REAL MODELS CAN'T WALK.
OKAY, SO DO WE
HAVE ANYTHING?
UH, GIVE HER BLACK.
IS IT WORKING?
TOCCARA, SHE WOULD BE
A GOOD MODEL FOR PEOPLE
WHO WOULD WANT THAT KIND
OF A GIRL.
♪♪♪
Amanda: MAY I JUST
WORSHIP FOR A SECOND?
- Cynthia: (laughs)
- Amanda: JUST KIDDING.
Cynthia:
YOU'RE SO FUNNY.
- I LIKE YOUR SHOES.
- Amanda: THANK YOU.
I PICKED THEM UP TODAY.
Cynthia: YOU HAD TIME
TO SHOP TODAY? NICE!
YOU'RE CUTE.
SO CAN YOU WALK FOR US?
- Cynthia: SHE CAN'T WALK.
- Man: I KNOW.
Cynthia:
GREAT. PERFECT.
Man: SHE'S GOOD.
Cynthia: OH, NICE!
PERFECT, YEAH.
Man: WHOA!
Toccara: THE DRESSES
THAT WERE MY SIZE,
THEY WERE REALLY BIG
AND NO SHAPE AND NO FORM.
I HAVE TO WORK TWICE AS HARD
JUST TO BE ON THE SAME LEVEL
AS THE OTHER GIRLS.
♪♪♪
Marc: ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, SO STRONG
AND SEXY, NOT TOO FUSSED.
PRETEND WE'RE NOT HERE.
Nicole: TODAY IS LIKE
A 12-HOUR DAY.
I MEAN,
IT'S RIDICULOUSLY TIRING,
AND MODELING IS
VERY DIFFICULT.
Marc: JUST KICK YOUR FEET
FORWARD AS YOU WORK.
OOPS.
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S TRY THAT AGAIN.
WHOOPS.
TOCCARA'S A MOVIE STAR.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY, LET'S TRY TO WALK
WITHOUT TRIPPING THIS TIME.
THAT'S TOO FAST.
Norelle: I'M JUST
CONCENTRATING, LIKE,
THE MOST ON NOT FALLING.
Marc: A LITTLE
WOBBLY ON THOSE HEELS.
Norelle: I'M TRYING TO WORK IT
THE BEST THAT I CAN.
Marc: I THINK YOU'RE
TOTALLY READY FOR THE RUNWAY.
GREAT JOB.
I LIKE THAT CONFIDENCE,
GREAT.
I THINK THAT YOUR THIGHS ARE
A LITTLE BIG FOR THIS DRESS.
I'M GONNA HAVE YOU WALK IN IT
WITH THE ZIPPER OPEN.
I THINK THE BIGGEST CONCERN
WITH CASSIE, FOR ME,
WAS THE SIZE OF HER HIPS.
I JUST WANT TO MEASURE
YOUR THIGHS
JUST TO SEE
WHERE WE'RE AT.
NORMALLY WE LIKE ABOUT
NO MORE THAN 35.
Cassie: I THINK
I'M RIGHT AT THAT.
Marc: YOU'RE AT 39.
OKAY, I PREFER
A SMALLER HIP.
Cassie: I DON'T APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT HE TOLD ME
THAT MY HIPS AND BUTT
WERE TOO BIG
FOR HIS PERSONAL TASTE.
I DON'T NEED TO MODEL
FOR MARC BOUWER.
Man: YOU'VE MADE
HER PERSONALITY EQUAL.
SHE OPENED HER UP TO A 42.
Yaya: AT THE END,
MARC BOUWER IS THE ONE
THAT ANNOUNCES TOTAL SUM
SCORES FOR THE DAY.
Marc: OKAY, GIRLS,
STARTING FROM THE LOWEST
TO THE HIGHEST,
NORELLE, YOU SCORED 170.
NICOLE, 178.5.
TOCCARA, 181.
CASSIE, 184.
EVA, 188.5.
AMANDA, 188.5.
AND THERE ARE TWO GIRLS THAT
ARE NECK AND NECK IN THIS.
YAYA, 211.
ANN...
207.5.
Girls: (cheering)
Marc: YAYA'S THE WINNER.
YOU'RE GONNA
CHOOSE A FRIEND,
AND YOU'RE GONNA RECEIVE
A RACK OF CLOTHES
FROM ALL THE DESIGNERS
THAT YOU SAW TODAY.
Yaya: NICOLE.
Nicole: THANK YOU.
Norelle: I FELT LIKE
I GAVE MY ALL TODAY
AND DIDN'T GET ANYWHERE.
Eva: CHECK IT,
YOU GIVE YOUR ALL,
AND SOMETIMES IT'S GREAT.
Norelle: AND IT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH, THOUGH.
IN THE SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN,
I DON'T HAVE THE LUXURY
TO SUCK OR TO BE
AT THE BOTTOM.
BEING LAST, IT MAKES ME
FEEL LIKE, "WHY AM I HERE?
LIKE, POINTLESS."
LIKE, I FEEL LIKE A JOKE.
Eva: YOU HAVE TO MAKE
YOURSELF STRONGER.
YOU STAND UP TALL AND
YOU SAY, "I'M NORELLE."
Amanda: YEAH,
OBSTACLES ARE NOTHING
BUT THINGS TO STEP OFF OF.
Toccara:
I WANNA SEE THIS.
Y'ALL BETTER COME OUT
BEFORE I LOOK AT IT FIRST.
YAYA WINS
THE GO-SEE CHALLENGE,
AND SHE WINS A RACK OF CLOTHES
FROM ALL THE DESIGNERS.
Yaya: FIVE, SIX, SEVEN,
EIGHT AND PICK A LETTER.
(gasping)
Amanda:
ARE THOSE FOR YOU, YAYA?
Yaya: SUGAR MAMA.
Nicole:
NO. THIS IS YAYA'S.
Yaya:
DELICIOUS SUGAR MAMA.
Amanda: OH, THAT IS ADORABLE.
Yaya: "DEAR YAYA, YOU DID
SUCH A GREAT JOB AT THE GO-SEE.
IT WAS A PLEASURE
TO HAVE MET YOU
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
A LOT ABOUT YOU IN THE FUTURE.
- LOVE, NANETTE."
- Ann: THAT'S ADORABLE.
LOOK AT YOU.
YOU'RE LIKE, "HEY."
Amanda: PUT IT ON.
PUT THAT ON. PUT IT ON.
Toccara: OKAY, I AIN'T
GONNA WATCH NO MORE.
I'M GOING BACK TO BED.
I AM VERY HAPPY FOR YAYA,
AND AT THE SAME TIME,
I WAS GETTIN' NERVOUS AND
SCARED BECAUSE YOU DON'T SEE
A LOT OF BIG GIRLS
IN HIGH FASHION.
Yaya: AW, THIS IS CUTE.
Toccara: I TOTALLY FEEL
A LOT OF PRESSURE
BECAUSE I'M HERE
WITH GIRLS WHO ARE ALL THIN
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
COMPETE WITH THEM.
COOL THEN.
LET ME GO TRY MY CLOTHES.
I'LL BE BACK.
Norelle: I THINK
I'M NOT DOING GOOD.
Norelle's mom: Well, you're
doing the best that you can.
Norelle: YEAH,
BUT THAT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
AND I FELT GOOD, AND, LIKE,
I WAS THE WORST ONE HERE.
AT FIRST I WAS SO MAD THAT
I FEEL LIKE I'M GIVING MY ALL
BUT IT'S STILL NOT COMING OUT
THE WAY I WANT IT TO COME OUT.
Norelle's mom: Remember,
it's up to you to see
the beauty in you,
you know?
And you know what? I want you
to start doin' this, too.
I want you to put
your arms around yourself
and hug yourself.
Norelle: SHE WAS JUST
TELLING ME, LIKE, LITTLE THINGS,
WHICH SOUND LIKE LITTLE THINGS,
LIKE, MOM, SHUT UP,
BUT THEY REALLY DO HELP.
I MAY NOT BE
GOOD ENOUGH NOW,
BUT I'LL BE GOOD ENOUGH
SOMEDAY.
Norelle's mom:
You're good enough now.
- I love you.
- Norelle: LOVE YOU, TOO.
- Norelle's mom: Bye.
- Norelle: BYE.
Norelle's mom:
Give you a kiss kiss.
Norelle: BYE, MOM.
Amanda: WE GO TO
THE SUNBURNT COW FOR DINNER,
THIS GREAT LITTLE
AUSTRALIAN RESTAURANT.
Toccara: ISN'T THIS
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS?
Waiter: HOW ARE YOU ALL
DOING THIS EVENING?
I'LL TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE MENU THIS EVENING.
THE SPECIALTIES OF THE HOUSE--
DEFINITELY THE ROO LINE.
THAT'S KANGAROO.
YOU KNOW, YOU WANNA TRY
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
Cassie: A DIET COKE
WITH LIME, PLEASE.
THIS WEEK HAS BEEN
PROBABLY THE HARDEST
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE.
Cassie: MARC BOUWER
PISSED ME OFF
'CAUSE HE'S LIKE, "OH, OKAY,
SO YOU'RE ACTUALLY..."
Marc: I JUST WANNA
MEASURE YOUR THIGHS
JUST TO SEE WHERE WE'RE AT.
OKAY, WE'RE AT 39.
I PREFER A SMALLER HIP.
Cassie: I FELT JUST KIND OF
SINGLED OUT FOR SOME REASON.
Nicole: CASSIE HAS A LOT
GOING ON BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
SHE SEEMS REALLY EMOTIONAL
INSIDE, REALLY UNSURE.
Ann: WHO'D HAVE THUNK
A KANGAROO TASTED THIS GOOD?
Cassie: THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
THINGS GOING THROUGH MY HEAD,
AND IT'S JUST REALLY
CLOUDY UP HERE.
Norelle: I HAVE NO
MODELING EXPERIENCE WHATSOEVER
AND SIX CUTS LATER,
I AM STILL HERE.
I'VE PROGRESSED
SO MUCH, AND AS MUCH
AS I BEAT MYSELF UP, LIKE,
I THINK THAT I JUST SEE
PROGRESSION IN MYSELF.
WHETHER THEY SEE IT OR NOT
OR WHETHER THEY THINK
I'M TRYING MY HARDEST,
I KNOW THAT I AM.
I MAY SEEM, LIKE, A LITTLE GOOFY
AND I THINK I COME OFF
AS, LIKE, I'M NOT
SERIOUS ABOUT THIS,
BUT I AM, LIKE,
DEAD SERIOUS ABOUT IT.
Amanda:
LOOK AT NORELLE.
Ann: LOOK AT
NORELLE'S BOOTY.
NORELLE'S, LIKE, JUST A SLUT.
- Norelle: AAH!
- Ann: NORELLE!
BUT I THINK THERE WAS
SOMETHING IN THE KANGAROO
'CAUSE WE LEFT
THAT RESTAURANT,
AND WE'RE, LIKE, LOOPY
IN THE CAR.
Yaya: IT'S SO WEIRD
WHEN TWO GIRLS KISS.
KISS HER. KISS HER.
Toccara: KISS HER!
Ann: WE THINK IT'S FUNNY
BECAUSE NORELLE--
SHE IS THE MOST INNOCENT,
LIKE, GIRL YOU'VE EVER MET.
LET'S HAVE A 4-WAY KISS.
AND SHE SAT IN THE CAR,
SHE GOES, "I KISSED ANN,"
AND WE JUST START LAUGHING
BECAUSE THIS IS--
NORELLE'S, LIKE,
COMING OUT OF HER SHELL.
All: (laughing)
Eva: WE'RE GETTING
IN THE JACUZZI.
Ann: WE GOT THE JACUZZI.
WE'RE GOING IN ALL NAKED.
Yaya: WE ARE HAVING
A PARTY IN THE LOUNGE.
SO HOW ABOUT YOU HAVE YOUR PARTY
AND WE'LL HAVE OURS?
Ann: ALL RIGHT.
Yaya: THEY ARE
OUT OF CONTROL.
Eva: THAT'S A LOT
OF WHITE PEOPLE.
Amanda: JUMP IN
THE HOT TUB TOGETHER,
WHICH WAS FUN AND NICE,
AND IT JUST BRINGS OUT
YOUR BAD SIDE.
All: (giggling)
Yaya: IT'S ALL ABOUT
THE TASTE.
Nicole:
TO ALL THAT HAVE LEFT
AND TO THOSE THAT
WILL REMAIN.
Toccara:
OH, BEAUTIFUL.
Yaya: YAY.
Cassie: NO,
HE COULD NOT BE, MOM.
Cassie's mom: Well, I mean,
he's doin' better, so--
he's on the antibiotics
and stuff...
Cassie: I FOUND OUT THAT
MY UNCLE IS REALLY SICK,
AND FAMILY MEANS
A LOT TO ME,
AND I QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT
I SHOULD BE HERE.
I DON'T WANT TO STAY,
ESPECIALLY WITH UNCLE MIKE SICK.
Cassie: I AM.
Cassie's mom:
No matter what. Love you, baby.
- Cassie: I LOVE YOU, TOO.
- Cassie's mom: Bye-bye.
Cassie:
ALL RIGHT, BYE.
I DON'T WANNA BE HERE
ANYMORE,
BUT I DON'T WANNA BE THE GIRL
KNOWN AS THE ONE THAT QUIT.
Yaya: TYRA MAIL!
LET'S GO READ THEM
NASTY ASSES.
COME. TYRA MAIL.
EW, EW, EW.
GO STAY OVER THERE, PLEASE.
"FROM WEEK TO WEEK, THE STRESS
IS GETTING WORSE AND WORSE,
AND TOMORROW YOU'LL DOUBLE OVER
FROM ALL THE STRAIN."
"YOU'LL DOUBLE OVER
Cassie: I STILL WANNA BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I'M STILL GONNA
GIVE 110%
WHEN I'M IN FRONT
OF THAT CAMERA.
Yaya: SO WE GET
TO THE PHOTO SHOOT.
THERE'S THIS DUDE STANDING
THERE WAITING FOR US.
All: YAY!
J.: WHAT UP, YO?
WHAT'S UP? WHAT'S UP?
WHAT'S UP?
Yaya:
YO, YO, YO, WHAT'S UP?
I WAS LIKE, "MISS J"?
J.: MORNIN'.
WHAT'S HAPPENIN'?
SO TODAY WE HAVE SOMEONE HERE
BECAUSE JAY MANUEL
WILL NOT BE HERE TODAY,
SO WE HAVE SOMEBODY ELSE.
HERE IT IS.
COME ON OUT. WHERE IS SHE?
All: OHH!
J.: WORK IT OUT.
Cassie: THIS WOMAN WALKS OUT,
AND I THOUGHT,
"THIS IS
A REALLY UGLY WOMAN."
J.:
WORK IT OUT. WORK IT OUT.
Jay: YOU BETTER ALL
GIVE IT UP FOR ME...
All:
(cheering and screaming)
Toccara:
AND SHE OPENS HER MOUTH
AND I'M LIKE,
"AAH! THAT'S JAY."
Jay:
I KNOW I'M GORGEOUS.
Cassie: AND I'M
JUST LIKE, "GROSS."
- J.: DAMN, WOMAN--
- Jay: DON'T TOUCH.
Cassie: BECAUSE
HE LOOKED LIKE A WOMAN.
AND THAT'S NOT STUFF YOU SEE
EVERY DAY IN OKLAHOMA.
Jay: FOR THOSE WHO HAVEN'T
FIGURED IT OUT,
YES, IT IS JAY.
THIS IS
THE ONE AND ONLY TIME
I WILL EVER DRESS
LIKE A WOMAN
TO ILLUSTRATE A POINT--
THE POWER OF TRANSFORMATION.
DO YOU HAVE
WHAT IT TAKES TO BECOME
A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PERSONA
OTHER THAN YOURSELF?
TODAY YOU'RE GOING TO BE DOING
A PHOTO SHOOT WITH A TWIST.
YOU'LL BE DOING
TWO SHOTS DRESSED UP
AS TWO EXTREMELY OPPOSITE
PERSONAS.
THEN WE'LL PUT THE TWO IMAGES
TOGETHER INTO ONE PHOTOGRAPH.
YOUR CHALLENGE WILL BE
TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE
THESE TWO ALTER EGOS ARE
INTERACTING WITH EACH OTHER.
All: YAY.
Jay:
NOW THE FORD MUSTANG
IS GONNA SET THE SCENE FOR
ALL OF YOUR SHOTS TODAY.
THE MUSTANG REPRESENTS
SEXUALITY, GRIT, TOUGHNESS,
AND IT'S UNMISTAKABLY
MUSTANG,
AND IT'S A CULTURAL ICON,
LIKE MYSELF.
Toccara: SO I'M IN THE
MODELING BOOT CAMP RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS TRULY BOOT CAMP.
I'M GETTING READY
FOR THE REAL WORLD, BABY.
Jay: CHILD,
MY FEET ARE KILLING ME.
SO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY,
DAVIDE,
HAS SHOT
ALL OVER THIS WORLD.
HE'S AN ACCLAIMED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
- Ann: HEY.
- Jay: COME HERE, SWEETIE.
THIS IS DAVIDE.
THEY'RE GORGEOUS, RIGHT?
Davide: OH, MY GOD.
Danillo:
TODAY'S A BIG DAY.
IT'S A COOL DAY.
Michele:
STRIP DOWN, BABY.
- Danillo: MARILYN MANSON.
- Amanda: YEAH.
Danillo:
IT'S THAT EXTREME.
Amanda: I'M A MODEL.
Eva: OH, COLD.
Jay: GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M BACK.
Norelle: MR. JAY TOLD US
THAT WE WERE GONNA BE
TWO DIFFERENT PEOPLE--
OUR REGULAR DAY PERSON
AND THEN OUR ALTER EGO.
BUT I HAD NO IDEA--
THE POWER OF TRANSFORMATION.
Davide: LEFT, LEFT, LEFT.
NO. RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT.
RIGHT THERE. HOLD IT.
Norelle: IT'S KIND OF
LIKE ACTING.
I HAD TO BE SHOCKED
AND THERE WAS NOTHING
TO BE SHOCKED AT
'CAUSE THEY WERE GONNA PUT
THE TWO COMPOSITES TOGETHER,
SO MY REGULAR NORELLE,
I JUST STAND THERE
AND BE LIKE, (gasps)
Jay: CAN YOU EVEN DO THIS?
Norelle: YEAH.
Jay: EVERY SHOOT NORELLE
LOOKS LIKE A KEWPIE DOLL.
TODAY SHE'S A STRONG
AMAZON WOMAN.
Norelle: IT WAS JUST BEING TWO
DIFFERENT PEOPLE IN ONE SHOT.
Jay: OH,
IT'S GORGEOUS, NORELLE.
Ann: I'VE ONLY TAKEN
ONE GOOD PICTURE.
LIKE, IF I HAVE
A BAD PICTURE TODAY,
I WOULD BE THE ONE GOING HOME,
AND I KNOW THAT.
Jay: 'CAUSE, LOOK,
IF YOU'RE HERE,
YOU'RE LIKE THIS.
- EXACTLY. AY.
- Ann: SORRY.
Davide: GO.
OKAY, NOW ONE MORE.
BELLA. FANTASTICA.
Jay: CAN YOU GIVE ME SOME
WITHOUT THAT MOUTH?
HEY, ANN,
THE MOTION AND THE INTENT
AND EVERYTHING IS AMAZING.
Jay: CAN I ZIP YOU UP?
IT'S LIKE A BAND-AID.
Davide: AND, WOW,
WHAT A BODY.
Ann: THIS SECOND ONE
WAS MORE NORMAL,
LIKE A SNOTTY RICH GIRL.
Jay: YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
PRETEND THERE'S SOMEONE HERE,
BUT I WANT IT TO BE LIKE
YOU'RE KICKING ME.
YOUR ALTER EGO WILL
PROBABLY BE ACTING WITHIN HERE.
Davide: GOOD.
BELLISIMA. (speaks Italian)
YES. YES. BRILLIANT.
Jay: DON'T POSE, EVA.
PRETEND LIKE SHE'S THERE.
Davide: FANTASTIC.
Jay: IN THIS ONE
YOU LOOK LIKE A STAR.
Eva: I AM.
Jay: I WANT YOU TO REACT
BY REACHING AROUND MY NECK.
THERE YOU GO. YES.
Cassie: ...WIDE HIPS.
Michele: WHICH IS A GOOD THING,
NOT A BAD THING.
Cassie: NO, MARC BOUWER
TOLD ME I WAS TOO BIG.
Jay: SO USE THE WHIP TO KIND
OF ANTAGONIZE THIS ONE.
YEAH.
FACE UP TO THE LIGHT
AND SHOW THE BUTT.
Cassie: I DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT THIS IS,
BUT I GUESS IT'S A GOOD OPPOSITE
OF BEING REALLY SWEET.
Jay: AND REMEMBER--
AND SHOW DISGUST.
Cassie: THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
THINGS GOING THROUGH MY HEAD.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT MY UNCLE
THAT MIGHT BE DYING,
AND I HOPE IT DOESN'T
COME OUT IN MY PICTURES.
Jay: TRY TO PUT YOUR HAND
THROUGH THEM
SO IT'S LIKE, I MEAN,
DOING THIS, BUT WE'LL--
WE'LL DIGITALLY DO IT SO IT'S
LIKE THE HAND IS GOING THROUGH.
Davide: AND JUST LIKE...
NICE. YES, YES, YES.
PERFECT.
Jay: YOU'RE REVEALING
YOURSELF TO HER FOR A REASON
'CAUSE YOU ARE A GHOST.
Yaya: THIS LOOK IS THAT
OF 17th CENTURY COURTESAN.
Davide: YAYA,
AS A FIRST TIME,
PERFECT
THE SECOND TIME, TOO.
ALTER EGO.
IT WAS BRILLIANT.
Jay: A LOT OF THE GIRLS ARE
PLAYING IT KIND OF SCARED.
Amanda: LIKE,
ARE YOU GONNA HURT ME?
Davide: WE'RE GONNA
HURT YOU. WE'LL HURT YOU.
Jay: CAN YOU SEE
IF YOU'RE ALMOST--
TRY AND CHEAT YOUR FACE
THAT WAY
'CAUSE WE GOTTA SEE
ALL THAT AMAZING MAKEUP.
YEAH, GREAT. THAT'S GREAT.
Michele: WHAT SIZE
DID YOU TELL ME YOU WORE?
A 12 OR IS IT REALLY A 14?
Toccara: I LOOK LIKE
I WORK AT A BOWLING ALLEY.
Michele:
NO, YOU DON'T.
Toccara: I WANNA KNOW
WHY ALL THE GIRLS
WERE SO NICE-LOOKIN',
AND HERE I AM LOOKIN' LIKE
I WORK AT HOME DEPOT.
Michele: YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND, TOO, TOCCARA,
IF YOU WERE TO DO CATALOGS,
YOU KNOW,
FOR PLUS-SIZED MODELS
AND STUFF LIKE THAT--
Toccara: I KNOW,
BUT THIS IS HIGH FASHION.
THIS IS NOT CATALOG.
I GOT TO PROVE MYSELF
TO THE HIGH FASHION PEOPLE.
Michele: DO YOU THINK THAT
I'M GONNA BE ABLE TO GET
A RACK LIKE THIS LOADED
WITH CLOTHES IN YOUR SIZE?
Toccara: YOU CAN'T FIND
SOMETHING IN MY SIZE
SO I'M SUPPOSED TO FEEL BAD
BECAUSE--
YOU JUST SAID THAT.
YOU SAID I HAVE TO START--
Michele: YOU'RE TAKING
EVERYTHING AS A NEGATIVE.
I DON'T THINK
THAT YOU REALIZE
HOW THIS WHOLE MODELING
THING WORKS.
THERE'S, LIKE,
NO APPRECIATION.
- Toccara: AAH! MY GOD!
- Michele: OH, SORRY.
ALL RIGHT, YOU GOT PINCHED.
OH, MY GOD.
Toccara:
I KNOW. OH, MY GOD.
Michele: LET ME SEE.
Jay: THAT WAS LOUD.
Davide: OKAY.
Jay: OTHER HAND, THOUGH.
DAVIDE, LIKE,
SHE'S OPENING THE DOOR
FOR THE GLAMOROUS ONE,
BECAUSE, LOOK AT HER.
SHE'S THE PARKING ATTENDANT.
I WANNA FEEL YOUR PAIN.
I WANNA FEEL YOUR LONGING.
I DO WANT IT TO READ
A LITTLE MORE IN YOUR EYES
BECAUSE, HONESTLY,
YOUR WEAKEST POINT
IN YOUR PHOTOS
ARE YOUR EYES.
TOCCARA--TO TRY
AND LET DOWN THAT WALL
IS GONNA BE HER BIGGEST
CHALLENGE,
'CAUSE SHE'S AFRAID
TO ACT WITH HER EYES.
Michele: MAYBE SOME TAPE.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO REALLY
SEVERELY STRAP THEM DOWN.
Toccara: I'VE BEEN
DISAPPOINTED WITH MYSELF.
I ALLOWED OTHER PEOPLE
TO TAKE MY ENERGY,
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE MADE ME
FEEL SO BAD AND ASHAMED.
Jay: YOU'RE WORKIN'.
UH, JIM, FOR POSITIONING,
JUST GIVE ME MY KEYS,
AND CAN YOU GIVE ME A LITTLE...
(makes cracking sound)
YEAH, IT'S THE CAMERA'S
POINT OF VIEW. THAT'S GREAT.
CAN WE SEE THE SPACE
HERE, DAVIDE?
- Davide: PERFECT.
- Jay: THANK YOU.
Davide:
GOOD. STAY THERE.
GOOD.
Jay: YOU'VE GOT SUCH
A BEAUTIFUL FACE,
BUT YOUR EYES--THEY'RE
A NICE, SULTRY, ALMOND LOOK,
WHICH IS JUST, LIKE,
THIS SEXY LOOK,
BUT OFTENTIMES
IT CAN READ DEAD.
Toccara: I DON'T THINK
I DID A VERY GOOD JOB.
I SHOULD HAVE KEPT
A POSITIVE ATTITUDE,
LIKE, OKAY--I DON'T KNOW.
I REALLY LET IT
GET TO ME.
Yaya: EVEN THOUGH
THEY SAY THAT
THEY WELCOME
PLUS-SIZED MODELS,
YOU KNOW THAT THEY DON'T PAY
AS MUCH ATTENTION TO YOU,
AND YOU'RE HANDLING
YOURSELF VERY WELL.
YOU HAVE ONE THING.
LET'S HOPE IT FITS,
AND THAT'S IT,
SO YOU HAVE A RIGHT
TO BREAK DOWN.
Toccara:
AND SHE SHOULDN'T MAKE ME
FEEL LIKE THAT, YOU KNOW?
NOW LOOK AT WHAT
EVERYBODY ELSE HAD ON,
AND I KNOW I CAN'T
COMPARE MYSELF
TO EVERYBODY ELSE,
BUT, DAMN--
SLACKS
AND SKIRTS AND DRESSES.
I THINK IT'S JUST HARD
BECAUSE I'M STANDING,
JUST TRYING
TO BE SO GRATEFUL.
IT JUST MAKES ME GRATEFUL,
BUT IT HURTS.
Eva:
AND WE HAVE TYRA MAIL.
WHERE IS AMANDA?
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY SEVEN OF YOU
WILL CONTINUE
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU WILL BE
ELIMINATED."
Nicole: THE STRESS
IS INTENSIFIED.
THERE IS MORE OF A CHANCE THAT
I'M GOING HOME WITH EACH CUT.
Amanda:
I LOVE PINK POSITIVE.
Cassie: YOU NEVER KNOW
WHO'S GONNA GO,
AND I'VE LEARNED
TO STOP GUESSING,
BUT JUST FROM WHAT I SAW,
I THINK TOCCARA
HAD A REALLY HARD TIME
WITH THE BEAUTY SHOTS.
Toccara: I GUESS IT REALLY
UPSET ME, THE PHOTO SHOOT,
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
DISAPPOINTED WITH MYSELF.
Norelle: I'M STILL
EXTREMELY NERVOUS.
THIS IS THE KIND OF FOOD
YOU EAT WHEN YOU'RE DEPRESSED.
I'VE BEEN TRYING SO HARD
AND I'M SO PROUD OF MYSELF.
NICE AND FATTENING.
I'VE GONE THROUGH
SIX ELIMINATIONS
NOT BEING THE STRONGEST GIRL,
AND I'M STILL HERE.
Tyra: THE GROUP IS
GETTING SMALLER AND SMALLER.
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
OUR SEVENTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER TOWARDS
DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WE HAVE SOME AMAZING PRIZES.
YOU'LL RECEIVE
A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH THE TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING AGENCY, FORD MODELS;
A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE PHOTOGRAPHED
BY WORLD RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 COVER GIRL
COSMETICS CONTRACT.
NOW OF COURSE WE HAVE
SOME VERY OPINIONATED JUDGES--
JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS THE FIRST SUPERMODEL
EVER IN EXISTENCE.
NIGEL BARKER, WHO IS
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLÉ MARIN, A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST,
AND WE HAVE
OUR SPECIAL GUEST JUDGE--
AN AMAZING DESIGNER,
MARC BOUWER.
THIS WEEK
I TAUGHT YOU GUYS
HOW TO PRESENT YOURSELF
AT GO-SEES.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO SEE THAT FOR THEMSELVES.
THE FIVE OF US HERE REPRESENT
A FICTITIOUS FASHION LINE
BY THE NAME OF HOUSE
OF JE NE SAIS QUOI.
WE WANT YOU TO TELL US
WHY WE SHOULD HIRE YOU
TO BE OUR CAMPAIGN GIRL.
Tyra: WELCOME TO
THE HOUSE OF...
All: JE NE SE QUOI.
Nigel: THIS IS A PIECE
FROM OUR LATEST COLLECTION
- IN JE NE SE QUOI.
- Janice: (gasps)
Nicole: THE GAS MASK MEETS
THE RUNWAY, AND I-I LOVE IT.
Nigel: HOW DOES IT
MAKE YOU FEEL?
Ann: IT MAKES ME
FEEL BEAUTIFUL
AND KIND OF MYSTERIOUS.
Norelle: AND IT'S SO UNIQUE
AND IT'S SUPER, LIKE, QUIRKY.
Nigel: IS THIS SOMETHING
YOU'D LIKE TO WEAR?
Eva: UM...
I MEAN, IT WOULDN'T BE
MY EVERYDAY DRESS,
BUT I WOULD
DEFINITELY ROCK IT.
Janice: (French accent)
I SEE A BITTY BOUTON.
DO YOU HAVE A LITTLE SKIN
PROBLEM? JUST A LITTLE?
Yaya: IT'S
A MENSTRUAL BREAKOUT.
Janice: AAH!
Tyra: CASSIE, I WANT MY MUSE
TO LIVE INSIDE MY HOUSE WITH ME.
Cassie: I WOULD BE HONORED
TO LIVE WITH YOU, OF COURSE.
- Janice: WE ALL...
- All: LIVE TOGETHER.
Ann: I FIND THAT--I MEAN,
I FIND THAT A LITTLE ODD,
AND I'M NOT GONNA LIE
TO Y'ALL.
Toccara: IF THIS CAMPAIGN IS
REALLY A BIG CAMPAIGN FOR YOU,
WHY NOT MAKE IT
LARGER THAN LIFE?
Janice: I CAN SEE WITH YOU
IT WOULD BE LARGER THAN LIFE.
Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR EVALUATIONS.
SO THE FIRST GIRL
ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK IS EVA.
YOU HAD A PHOTO
WHERE YOU HAD TO EVOKE
THE POWER OF AN ALTER EGO.
Tyra: THAT'S ADORABLE.
- Marc: WOW, THAT'S AMAZING.
- Nolé: IT IS REALLY AMAZING.
Marc: IT TOOK ME
A WHILE TO REALIZE
THAT IT WAS YOU
IN BOTH POSES.
Janice: FINALLY YOU DIDN'T
TILT YOUR CHIN THAT FAR UP
SO WE CAN SEE
RIGHT UP YOUR NOSTRILS.
Tyra:
UP NEXT, WE HAVE ANN.
- Janice: HELLO.
- Nigel: OOH.
Marc: I JUST SEE SUCH
AMAZING POTENTIAL IN YOU,
AND I THINK THAT PHOTOGRAPH
IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
- Ann: THANK YOU.
- Tyra: ALL RIGHTY, CASSIE.
SO YOU HAD A CASTING
FOR THE HOUSE OF JE NE SE QUOI.
I SAID BLAH.
Nigel: I KNOW THAT
WE WERE LAUGHING,
WE WERE HAVING FUN WITH IT.
YOU HAVE TO BE HAPPY,
POLITE, NON-FAZED BY THAT.
Tyra:
ALL RIGHT, CASSIE, SO YOU HAD
AN ALTER EGO PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO SHOW
SOME STRENGTH.
- IT COULD BE STRONGER.
- Janice: EXACTLY.
EVEN IF YOU TOOK YOUR HANDS UP
AND DID DIVA.
Tyra: THE MAKEUP IS FIERCE,
THE HAIR IS FIERCE,
BUT YOUR FACE IS
A LITTLE BIT TOO RELAXED.
YOU'RE, LIKE,
KIND OF PUSHING THROUGH,
BUT NOT BURSTING THROUGH.
Nigel: JUST REALIZE
HOW GORGEOUS YOU ARE
AND BE FULL OF YOURSELF,
STRONG.
- Cassie: THANK YOU.
- Janice: BYE-BYE.
Tyra: AMANDA.
YEAH. IT'S SAD WHEN
THE JUDGES ARE JUST SILENT.
THAT MEANS IT'S BAD.
Nolé: THE WAY
YOU'RE HOLDING YOUR MOUTH
HAS NO FEELING TO ME.
Nigel: WE KNOW YOU'VE GOT
THAT CAPACITY TO PULL OUT
KILLER PICTURES
WITH YOUR EYES,
AND THE WHOLE THING,
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE, UH...
Tyra: UP NEXT, NORELLE.
Marc: I'D LIKE YOU TO DEVELOP
A LITTLE MORE CONFIDENCE.
I WANNA SEE SOME SPARK.
I WANNA SEE "I'M NORELLE."
Tyra: I WANT YOU
TO TRY SOMETHING.
I WANT YOU TO PUT
ONE OF YOUR HANDS ON YOUR HIP
AND KIND OF, LIKE, GO--
Norelle: WELL,
I'D PROBABLY DO THIS ONE.
Tyra: THAT LOOKS BETTER.
THERE'S CONFIDENCE NOW
INSTEAD OF "HI."
Janice: OH, MY GOD.
Nigel: WHOA.
Marc: THE SECRETARY LOOK
IS NOT WORKING FOR YOU.
Janice: NO, NOT AT ALL.
- THAT WORKS.
- Tyra: GORGEOUS!
Nigel: IT'S ALMOST
AS IF YOU HAVE TO BE
DRESSED UP IN COSTUME
TO BECOME FIERCE.
Tyra: YAYA.
OH, THAT'S
THE PRETTIEST POSE.
- Janice: THAT'S FIERCE.
- Tyra: YEAH.
Yaya:
HARD TO SEE IT. WOW.
Tyra: SHE'S A GHOST.
THAT'S YOUR WEAKEST
PICTURE YET.
Janice: IT IS WEAK.
Tyra: YEAH, THAT DOESN'T
LOOK LIKE A MODEL TO ME.
NICOLE.
Janice: PROM,
DEBUTANTE, COCKTAIL.
Nolé: NOT GOOD.
Nigel: WE KNOW YOU COULD DO
BETTER THAN THAT.
Janice: EVERYTHING
ABOUT IT'S WRONG.
Nicole: OKAY.
Tyra:
NEXT WE HAVE TOCCARA.
Janice: HAVE YOU EVER
IN HISTORY SEEN ANYONE
WALK DOWN THE RUNWAY
LIKE THAT?
Tyra: I THINK
THAT YOU'RE THE TYPE OF GIRL
THAT CAN HANDLE THIS CRAZY ASS
FASHION INDUSTRY
'CAUSE THERE ARE
SOME CRAZY FOOLS UP IN HERE.
THIS HOUSE OF JE NE SE QUOI
IS ONLY A LITTLE TASTE.
IN YOUR MIND,
I'M SURE YOU WERE LIKE,
"THEY'RE CRAZY. THEY'RE CRAZY,
BUT THEY WANT THIS,
AND I'M-A GIVE IT TO 'EM."
YOU KNOW?
BUT, HEY, I WAS LIKE,
"SHE'S FANTABULOUS."
Janice: THERE'S NOTHING
MODELLY ABOUT IT. NEXT.
Nolé: IT'S A PRETTY SHOT,
BUT IT NEEDS TO HAVE MORE
PASSION BEHIND THE EYES.
IT ALWAYS GOES
BACK TO THE EYES FOR ME.
Janice: THIS IS NOT
VERSATILE ENOUGH
TO BE TOP MODEL.
- IT'S JUST NOT. I'M SO SORRY.
- Nigel: NO. I AGREE WITH YOU.
Tyra: THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
YOU'RE GIVIN' IT.
Nolé: GLAMOUR, DARLING.
I WANNA BE PLATINUM, TOO.
Tyra: NOW IT'S TIME
TO DELIBERATE.
YAYA.
DO YOU WANNA START?
Janice:
I'M PULLING FOR YAYA.
Nolé: IN THIS PHOTO,
HALF OF IT IS AMAZING.
THE OTHER HALF,
SHE DIDN'T NAIL IT.
Tyra: ANN.
Marc: I HAVE SEEN THE STARTS
OF MANY GREAT MODELS.
ANN HAS THAT.
Tyra: THIS PICTURE
IS REALLY STRONG.
Nigel: ANN HAS REALLY UPPED
THE ANTE THIS WEEK FOR HERSELF.
Tyra: NICOLE.
Nolé: SHE HAS
AN INCREDIBLE FACE.
Tyra: I DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT HER.
SHE SMILES
AND SHE'S KIND OF CUTE,
BUT THEN SHE WALKS OUT AND
I'M LIKE, "WHO WAS THAT?"
AMANDA.
Nigel: I THINK THIS IS
THE WORST PICTURES
THAT SHE'S TAKEN,
FOR ME, ANYWAY.
Marc: IF AMANDA BUILDS
A REALLY STRONG EDITORIAL BOOK,
SHE CAN DEFINITELY HAVE
A SUCCESSFUL CAREER IN FASHION.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Nolé: I'VE NEVER BEEN
A BIG FAN OF NORELLE'S,
BUT SHE HAS GROWN ON ME.
Janice: NORELLE'S WALK
BELONGS IN A CIRCUS.
Tyra: NORELLE IS PROGRESSING,
BUT HER PACE IS WAY TOO SLOW.
EVA.
Nigel: EVA REALLY
SHINES THIS WEEK.
I MEAN, SHE NAILED IT.
Janice:
EVA'S STILL SHORT.
Nigel: PERHAPS SHE'LL GROW
BY NEXT WEEK.
Tyra: TOCCARA.
Nolé: SHE IS
A POWERFUL INDIVIDUAL,
AND IN THIS SHOT, I DON'T THINK
THE PASSION WAS THERE.
Nigel: THIS IS A LITTLE WEAK
ON ONE SIDE OF THE PICTURE.
Janice: A LITTLE WEAK?
THE CAR LOOKS BETTER
THAN SHE DOES.
IF THE BODY COULD JUST
SLIM DOWN 150 POUNDS,
THAT WOULD BE GOOD.
Tyra: THEN SHE'D BE
30 POUNDS.
Janice:
THAT WOULD BE BETTER.
Marc: SHE'S NOT
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
IT'S LUDICROUS TO THINK
THAT SHE WOULD BE.
Janice: IT WILL
NEVER BE TOP MODEL.
Tyra: THE THINGS
THAT YOU GUYS SAY
ARE THE SAME THINGS
PEOPLE SAID ABOUT KATE MOSS.
"SHE'S SO SHORT."
"WE'VE NEVER HAD
A TOP MODEL THAT TINY."
- Marc: TOCCARA IS OUT.
- Nigel: TOCCARA IS IN.
Tyra: CASSIE.
Nolé: I LOVE THE POSE,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
IN FASHION YOU HAVE TO WORK
WITH SOMEONE ALL DAY LONG,
YOU HAVE TO BE
PASSIONATE ABOUT THEM.
I WOULD NOT
BOOK THIS GIRL.
Tyra: BUT CASSIE'S FACE
IS UNDENIABLE.
I JUST WANT HER
TO WANNA BE HERE.
Nigel: SHE NEEDS
TO REALIZE HOW PRETTY SHE IS
AND SORT OF TURN IT OUT,
BUT I'M NOT SURE
THAT SHE HAS THAT CAPACITY.
I'M AFRAID CASSIE'S OUT.
Janice:
CASSIE OVER TOCCARA?
Marc: CASSIE HAS
MUCH MORE POTENTIAL
TO BE A SUCCESSFUL MODEL
THAN TOCCARA HAS.
Nigel: CASSIE--
THIS KIND OF PRETTINESS
IN A GIRL IS A DIME A DOZEN.
TOCCARA--THERE'S JUST
SOMETHING ABOUT HER.
- SHE'S INTERESTING.
- Janice: YEAH, A LOT OF FLESH.
Tyra: YOU COULD HAVE VOTED HER
OUT THE FIRST WEEK.
- WHY WASTE HER TIME?
- Janice: DIDN'T I?
Tyra: NO, YOU DIDN'T.
WHY WASTE HER TIME
AND TELL HER THAT SHE COULD
BE THE ONLY GIRL
THAT COULD EVER WIN
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
THAT'S A PLUS SIZE?
Janice: YOU'RE
THE FIRST PLUS-SIZED GIRL
THAT I COULD SAY
COULD MAKE IT.
Tyra: IT'S FINE
TO HAVE A STANCE,
BUT FOR YOU TO SAY
ONE THING
AND THEN SAY SOMETHING
THE NEXT--STICK WITH IT.
Janice:
I GIVE UP. I JUST--
Tyra: I JUST SEE A LOT
OF DISCRIMINATION.
Tyra: I HAVE
EIGHT BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STANDING BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SEVEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
THESE PHOTOS
REPRESENT THE SEVEN OF YOU
THAT WILL CONTINUE
ON THE JOURNEY
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL...
EVA.
EVA, THIS PICTURE
IS TO DIE FOR.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Eva: THANK YOU.
Tyra: ANN.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE GIRL
THAT DIDN'T KNOW
HOW TO TAKE PICTURES?
Ann: I DON'T KNOW.
Tyra:
I THINK YOU'VE SHOWN US
THAT THERE IS A LITTLE
SOMETHING IN YOU,
ALITTLE SOMETHING
EXTRA SPECIAL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YAYA.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NORELLE.
WHEN YOU'VE GOT
AN ELABORATE COSTUME ON,
GIRL, YOU'RE FIERCE.
BUT WHEN THE MAKEUP
IS ALL SIMPLE,
YOUR CONFIDENCE
JUST DISAPPEARS.
A TOP MODEL HAS TO USE
THEIR IMAGINATION.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Norelle: THANK YOU.
Tyra: AMANDA.
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- Amanda: THANK YOU.
Tyra: THE NEXT NAME
I'M GOING TO CALL--
NICOLE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Nicole: THANK YOU.
Tyra: WILL TOCCARA AND CASSIE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND I WILL ONLY
CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE APARTMENT,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS,
AND LEAVE.
ONE OF YOU SEEMS
TO HAVE SUCH JOY
AND SUCH A VIVACIOUS
AND CONTAGIOUS PERSONALITY.
THE OTHER DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
THEY WANNA BE HERE AT ALL.
ONE OF YOU A LOT OF THE JUDGES
REALLY BELIEVE IN
AND THINKS THAT, "EVEN THOUGH
SHE MIGHT NOT WANNA BE HERE,
SHE COULD HAVE A CRACK
AT BEING A MODEL."
AND THE OTHER
A LOT OF JUDGES THINK,
"THERE'S NO PLACE FOR HER
IN THIS INDUSTRY.
IT'S NOT GONNA CHANGE.
THIS IS THE WAY IT IS
AND THIS IS THE WAY
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN."
TONIGHT'S JUDGING
WAS VERY DIFFICULT.
Tyra: TOCCARA,
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Toccara: THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
Tyra: THANKS, CASSIE.
Cassie: I JUST HAD
A FEELING IT WOULD BE ME
JUST BECAUSE
I WAS UNHAPPY HERE.
I DON'T WANNA LIVE
IN NEW YORK CITY
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
I HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
I FEEL LIKE I'M JUST WITH
GIRLS I DON'T LIKE.
I JUST WANNA BE WITH
MY BOYFRIEND AND MY MOM.
I DON'T EVER WANNA LIVE WITH
A GROUP OF GIRLS AGAIN.
LET'S GO TO OKLAHOMA.
Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
HERE'S WHAT'S COMIN' UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Ann: TO THE SEVENS.
Tyra: THE COMPETITION
HEATS UP.
Men: YAYA! YAYA!
Tyra: AND THE GIRLS
GET IN TOUCH
WITH THEIR INNER DIVAS.
Woman: WHO'S THE MOST
ANNOYING GIRL IN THE GROUP?
Eva: EVERYONE'S
EQUALLY ANNOYING.
Tyra: AND AT THE PHOTO SHOOT
EVA LOSES HER COOL...
- Woman: SHE'S CRYING.
- Amanda: REALLY?
Tyra: WHEN SHE FACES
HER BIGGEST FEAR.
Eva: SORRY.
I'M SO SORRY. I'M SO SORRY.
Jay: SHE COULD GET CUT
'CAUSE OF THIS.